because everyone was like this is such a
silly idea and they raised all this
money I mean I guess at the heart of
what liquid death really is we're really
just completely trying to change the way
healthy food and beverages are marketed
at the end of the day most of the most
hilarious memorable ad campaigns that
you ask most people about it the last 10
years they'll tell you Bud Light don't
suck ease Snickers Doritos skittles like
all junk food and alcohol that's the
funniest most memorable kind of youth
culture owning and energy drinks like
redbull that's like let's not leave old
spice out well it's not really a pure
beverage but yes but yeah it's like all
that it's all junk food and alcohol that
does all the funniest coolest youth
culture marketing
whereas healthy food is traditionally
marketed to like mom and it's quiet and
it's responsible or it's like look
better we're you know show yo you know
fitness models you know drinking bottles
of water like it's a very different they
don't use fun to market whereas
unhealthy beverages stuff like that like
they want to own fun
so we're basically doing that with water
so we want to be able to take the
healthiest thing you can drink that most
people don't drink enough of and brand
it and build a you know a cool you know
seeing around it where it's something
that you feel totally comfortable
drinking a liquid death in a bar or at a
house party right at a music festival or
at work or in the gym and just making it
more fun to walk around and have a walk
right and you definitely made headlines
when you raised all that money cuz
everyone was like this is such a silly
idea and they raised all this money I
didn't
it's a stupid reason I mean it was like
an awesome company and totally worthy of
going big but so it kind of worked
right like you you definitely uh you
definitely ruffled some feathers and I
think that's good no yeah I think you
know I always bring up I one of the you
know I listen to the Reed Hoffman
podcast a lot master scale yeah and it's
like I loved it he always pushes he's
like truly innovative ideas are almost
comical at first because if it seems
like it makes a lot of sense right now
it probably means there's four other
companies that have been working on it
for five years already
looks like the things that are truly
unique and innovative like almost don't
make any sense at first there seem
laughable I think like that's kind of
the case of liquid death I think it's
like we're really trying to disrupt a
category in a way that's not just
disruption for the sake of disruption
you know I think it's like we strongly
believe that and I don't think it's
something hard to understand you know in
a category where almost all the products
themselves are perceived as the same you
know people are assuming I only drink
Fiji because it's got 0.75 more
electrolytes than smart water which has
0.5 the pH is 7 point 7 it said 7 no
it's like most people assume water is
the same it's more of a brand play and
we believe if we can make you laugh we
have a way better chance at you giving
us your dollar 69 then the faceless
brand next to us who's trying to shout
at you electrolyte to let you know
they're like guys this all seems like
snake oil to me like I feel like there's
real human beings behind liquid debt
that I'd want to have a beer with so I'd
rather give you my my dollar 65 and
let's talk a little bit about the form
factor so is it's a it's a tall cam as
what I've seen are there other form
factors or no no it's just the talk game
it's all can which is cool the branding
of it is sort of like you know almost
like heavy metal or punk rock how do you
describe yeah yeah yeah I mean yeah I
think at the end of the day you would
you would say we're like alternative
punk metal inspired design and and vibe
I think the way I like to think about
our brand is like we're a professional
Resler like it's all theater and fun and
everyone thinks it's trying to be real
like no one thinks the undertaker is
really an evil guy from the dead who
likes metal no it's a character and it's
fun to like buy a character yeah and
that's kind of that's how we think about
it like we're just playing this fun
sorry second we're just playing this fun
character it's fun to choose to believe
that yeah this is what it is and not
take it too seriously and you're right
like you know if you're at a bar or a
music festival and you choose water you
feel like you're choosing you're opting
out of the fun and in fact they'll sort
of you know it'll make you feel that way
you know you'll get the small plastic
rinky-dink cup with the baby straw right
versus if you ordered a you know
alcoholic drink or something else it's
kind of that's actually a good point I
mean I don't drink and I still go to
bars and I always felt like I used to
order sprites with lime in it because I
was like looks like a gin and tonic yeah
my god one being people feel
uncomfortable what so I'll just even
though I don't like to drink soda like
I'll drink it anyway and I don't have an
O'Doul's because I'm like uh then
everyone's just kind of like it's just
gonna come up and so it's it is a great
alternative to that and so Mike I'm
curious where does this idea come from
so I think this was really just like a
culmination of all my passions and
experience sort of like converged into
one you know it's like I grew up in high
school playing in punk rock and metal
bands and skateboarding and you know I
would do all the show flyers and album
art and stuff for our bands which kind
of got like the entrepreneurial probably
side of things because like you know
we're booking shows and we're selling
merch and like we're pressing records
and doing all that kind of stuff then I
got into a career of like graphic design
which led into advertising so then I was
like an advertising creative director
for a long time and I worked on big
brands like Nestle and Toyota and
Volkswagen and Naked Juice and all this
kind of stuff so I think I got a good
sense of where I think big companies
screw up I guess like where I think
they're short-sighted I can't tell you
how many boardrooms I've been in where
I'm trying to convince
all that social media isn't some like
niche little thing you add on to your
business like it is the Internet
when you say I'm going on the Internet
nine times out of ten you're going on
social media you know it's like I think
a lot of brands are just way behind the
ball to understand what it really takes
to be successful in the social
environment like your little social
posts aren't just competing against
other beverages you're competing against
influencers who are uncensored and can
do crate easy on the wall you're again
trash you're competing against
everything awesome on the internet when
you're scrolling through your feed
that's what your marketing is competing
against so when you really think about
it that way do you really think your
little ad that seems like a typical
beverage thing is gonna actually stand
out in someone's quick scrolling feed
amongst all this other amazing stuff
probably not so I think the bar for what
stuff needs to be is way higher and I
think that's what I built liquid death
around like we think about marketing
like entertainment I don't ever want to
put something in your feed that feels
like marketing I wanted to feel like
actual entertainment that made you laugh
or it was the funniest thing that you
maybe saw that morning that you want to
share with your friends or whatever that
like we're never just sticking marketing
in your face like it's always going to
entertain you or it's gonna do something
of value that it gives you I've got
questions like Sam I'm looking at their
Facebook Ads right now and what you're
saying is true so here's the two ads I
see I wish I could show this through a
podcast so I'm gonna show this to your
ears but there's a giant can of liquid
death in front of a mountain and says
this is dumb don't buy this there's
another one that's like I don't know
what you'd call this it's like a it's
like the mountain from Game of Thrones
but instead of his head is a can
a liquid death erupting from his
muscular body and he's standing in a
grocery store aisle grocery store aisle
holding an axe and it just says like
this is a villain nationwide at Whole
Foods
I'm gonna I want to ask a question about
that but first is there any indication
is there anything you can give me the
shows or the listeners how big this
business is like what what size you guys
are yeah why should we why should we
care about what you say something or not
I want you to like impress people yeah I
mean I can't get into like specific kind
of sales numbers but since we launched
national and Whole Foods basically we
launched the day the pandemic started so
we went we went into Whole Foods March
15 and basically even even though we've
been in a pandemic where they've had
like 80% decreased store traffic and
everything else going on we've had
insane growth in Whole Foods and we're
now the fastest growing water bread in
Whole Foods right and you've raised like
how much money to make this far
grand total since the very beginning of
everything I think we've raised around
12 total right now so great okay so we
kind of have an idea a little bit about
sizing when you look at when you are
looking at this business and what and
what to start was that your perspective
which is what is something that I mean
it sounds like you're into health and
that type of stuff what is something
that is like good for you but has [__]
marketing and how can I build a business
around that was that your perspective in
a nutshell I think it really came from
you know you know where I grew up
playing in punk bands and and metal
bands and stuff like that I was still
and a lot of my friends in that world
were very much into health like I was a
vegetarian at age 16 a lot of my friends
in that scene were more my friends were
even vegan a lot of them like you know
didn't drink alcohol I do and I think
that's one thing that we've been like
misbranded is like liquid death its
water for the straightedge crowd that is
not what we're trying to do I think it's
something that's been adopted by them
for you know the reasons of yeah it is
more fun to walk around in a bar if you
don't want
drink than something like this but I
think another thing that the health food
industry does and I don't think we want
to do is we don't want to be preachy to
people we don't want to say you should
be doing this and I shouldn't be
drinking this and you shouldn't be doing
that like we're like hey you want to go
rip some shots at a bar fine but maybe
take a break and have a water for an
hour you know or like hey you want to
smoke weed or whatever it's like great
like maybe hydrate while you're doing it
right even it's like hey you want to go
buy a monster energy drink or whatever
great maybe buy water too and have a
water after you just pound a bunch of
[__] right happy that's the good news
anybody who does any lifestyle also
drinks water and spray compared to any
lifestyle that you want it sounds like
you guys trying to do that
[Music]
[Applause]